hablemos de la idea de impedancia en
redes sencillas aquí tenemos una red muy
sencilla con dos impedancia si en ella
se está uno y z 2a dentro de estas cajas
tenemos algunos de nuestros componentes
pasivos favoritos una r una l o una c
eso es lo que está adentro de estas
cajas vamos a ver algunas combinaciones
de esto para ver cuál será la impedancia
de las posibles combinaciones
cuando hablamos de impedancia hablamos
de señales senoidal es voltaje senoidal
es divididos entre corriente senoidal es
y esa proporción es la impedancia
nuestro voltaje está entre estas dos
terminales y la corriente y fluye de
esta forma y tenemos más menos de aquí y
la relación entre estas dos cosas se
llama impedancia tenemos un circuito con
dos impedancia conectadas en serie si
ambas impedancia fueran resistencias así
cuando escribimos la impedancia de un
registro escribimos r las que tenemos
aquí son r1 y r2 el efecto completo de
estas impedancia será de resistencias en
serie aquí no hay nada nuevo ahora
imaginemos una red que tiene una
resistencia con un capacitor y quiero
conocer la proporción de voltaje a
corriente o la impedancia de esto
este valor es r y la impedancia de un
capacitor es 1 / j o mega c y si
quisiera puedo escribirlo de la misma
forma menos j por 1 / omega se recuerden
que 1 / j es igual a menos j si quiero
conocer la impedancia de esta red y aquí
está el truco para hacer esta
transformación usaremos las mismas leyes
que conocemos para las resistencias en
este circuito transformado en el dominio
de la frecuencia la combinación de dos
impedancia en serie es la suma de las
impedancia r + 1 / j omega se está es la
impedancia de esta red de aquí
ahora hagamos una combinación con el
inductor aquí tenemos la resistencia y
aquí el inductor la impedancia de una
resistencia es r y la impedancia del
inductor es j
omega l escribimos la impedancia
combinada de esta red
tenemos impedancia es en serie por lo
que sumaremos r + j omega l ahora lo que
vamos a hacer es presentar una nueva
terminología para la impedancia veamos
estos dos ejemplos con el capacitor y el
inductor r es un número real 1 / j omega
c es un número imaginario y juntos
forman un número complejo aquí con el
inductor tenemos lo mismo una parte real
y una parte imaginaria la forma en la
que escribimos la impedancia en general
como un número rectangular complejo z
igual a r + j por x r es la resistencia
y el nombre de x significa en general
reactancia x es la parte imaginaria de
la impedancia y nos referimos a ésta
como la redactan cya también hablamos
del inverso de la resistencia
la conductancia es uno entre r y uno
entre x se llama sus estancia todas
estas palabras suenan algo similar pero
los ingenieros querían tener palabras
diferentes para las diferentes partes de
una impedancia y estas son las palabras
que se usan finalmente tenemos otra
palabra para el inverso de la impedancia
1 / zeta que es la admitan cya aquí
tenemos un nuevo vocabulario admitan cya
es lo opuesto a la impedancia sustancia
es el inverso de la redactan cya y
conductancia es lo inverso a la
resistencia estas son todas las palabras
que podemos pensar representan resistir
y permitir ahora veremos con más detalle
estas expresiones de la impedancia todos
estos son números complejos lo que
significa que puedo graficar los en un
plano complejo
hagámoslo para ver qué encontramos aquí
tenemos el eje real aquí el eje
imaginario para la resistencia tenemos
dos partes reales lo que nos da un
número
que graficar hemos por acá sumamos ambos
vectores y esto será z hagamos esto para
el siguiente circuito la capacitancia de
nuestro circuito rc una resistencia está
aquí este es el valor de r y como
gráfica moshe recuerden que ese es uno
entre jota omega c que también es igual
a menos j entre 1 omega se lo que nos da
una jota negativa por lo que tenemos una
línea hacia la parte negativa de j aquí
tenemos el valor de 1 / omega c y este
punto de aquí es z
ahora hagamos el siguiente circuito que
tiene el gráfica más nuestra ere y ahora
mj omega l tenemos una j positiva que
vale omega l digamos que el es pequeña
esto tiene una magnitud de omega l en el
eje imaginario lo que nos da el punto
para la z de esta red ahora imaginen que
omega está cambiando y omega aumenta se
moverá hacia arriba en el plano complejo
y o'mega cambia en este caso si omega
cambia y se hace más grande en el caso
del capacitor significa que este número
será más pequeño por lo que se moverá en
esta dirección
finalmente en el caso de la resistencia
no importación mega cambia ya que aquí
no tenemos ningún término con omega esto
nos muestra lo que ocurre de manera
gráfica cuando cambiamos la frecuencia
de una impedancia compleja vamos a hacer
uno más veamos este circuito que tiene
un inductor una resistencia y un
capacitor y queremos saber a qué es
igual z así que hagamos lo que hicimos
antes aquí
j omega l aquí está r y aquí está uno
entre j omega c ahora encontremos la
impedancia de esto y como nuestros
componentes están conectados en serie la
intedencia total es la suma de las
impedancia sense bien así que podemos
decir que z es igual a j omega el más r
más uno entre j omega c ahora vamos a
tratar de graficar esto aquí aquí
tenemos el eje real y aquí tenemos el
eje imaginario primero graphic hemos r
porque está sobre el eje real este es
ere y ahora gráfica mos j omega l tiene
su valor por aquí
este es el inductor representado con un
vector y 1 / j omega se estará en la
parte negativa del eje imaginario esta
impedancia vamos a hacerla un poco más
grande la magnitud de esto es 1 / omega
c y si ponemos todo esto junto tendremos
básicamente una suma de vectores
pongamos omega l por aquí para hacer la
suma de vectores este vector de aquí los
a los demás va hacia abajo así y la
respuesta final es este vector de aquí
esta es la zeta de nuestra red este
número complejo de aquí verán que
conforme cambiamos omega varias cosas
suceden y este punto se mueve con la
frecuencia y esto es la esencia del
análisis de sea nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo